hola muy buenas noches a andrés y
televidentes pues de las más de 3000
personas que había en este sitio muchas
ya se han ido quedan pocos pero los
pocos que quedan si se han mostrado
dispuestos a seguir las indicaciones de
federico gutiérrez del candidato quien
invitó a votar por el candidato rodolfo
hernández y lo que dice en su discurso
es que está en contra de gustavo petro
de las políticas de este candidato de
izquierda dice que la democracia está en
peligro que colombia está en peligro y
por eso invito a las personas que de una
vez cambiaron su discurso y ya empezaron
a mostrarse a favor de rodolfo hernández
inclusive muchas personas de derecha y
de extrema derecha en redes sociales ya
han invitado a hacer esta votación y es
que hay que hacer una cuenta muy
sencilla y es la siguiente petro tiene
8.5 millones de votos pero entre rodolfo
hernández y federico gutiérrez tienen un
total de 11 millones de votos así que si
atienden este llamado pues podrían
estarle ganando en la segunda vuelta que
es el próximo 19 de junio al candidato
de izquierda daniela ahora los grandes
derrotados con federico gutiérrez son
los partidos tradicionales y en
particular los seguidores del
expresidente álvaro uribe qué significa
la salida del juego del candidato
apadrinado por el gobierno de iván duque
y lo más granado del establecimiento
primero que colombia rompe con una
tradición de muchos años en la que
siempre han gobernado presidentes
conservadores de derecha muy
tradicionales muy ortodoxos y dan paso
hacia una presidencia más progresista
más populista pero también el otro
mensaje es que el establecimiento tiene
que unirse con una persona con la que no
han entendido pues es suficiente feeling
o una campaña con la que no se han
identificado y lo tienen que hacer a
regañadientes de hecho el llamado que
hace también federico gutiérrez en su
primer discurso después de reconocer la
derrota es a votar por el candidato
por el candidato rodolfo hernández pero
aclara un punto y es que no va a buscar
puestos en su administración no va a
buscar estar dentro de su gobierno
entonces ese es un mensaje también muy
importante y es que en las prácticamente
los votantes de la derecha se quedan sin
candidato y tienen que votar no ya por
un candidato de ellos propios sino en
contra de gustavo petro